good evening my fellow Americans the
gravity of the Moment underscored by a
rare Oval Office address President Joe
Biden has sought to convince Americans
weary of the war in Ukraine that the
United States must fund yet another
military conflict in Israel Hamas and
Putin represent different threats but
they share this in common they both want
to completely annihilated a neighboring
democracy completely
annihilated it's a tough sell for a
president who in 2019 promised voters
he'd end the forever Wars but Biden
argues not funding Ukraine and now
Israel's conflicts will embolden the
enemies of America's allies ultimately
putting Americans at risk American
alliances what keep us America safe
American values are what make us a
partner the other nations want to work
with to put all that at risk if we walk
away from Ukraine if we turn our backs
on Israel it's just not worth it we
will in a politically divided United
States where the FBI reports
islamophobic and anti-semitic attacks
are rising following the October 7th
attack in Israel Biden has cautioned
Americans not to give in to hate in
moments like these when fear and
suspicion anger and rage run hard that
we have to work harder than ever to hold
on to the value that make us who we are
instead the US president impressed on
Americans the importance of the moment
and stressed his convictions we cannot
and will not let terrorists like Hamas
and tyrants like Putin win I refuse to
let that happen that's why President
Biden is requesting Congress provide a
100 billion in security funding for
Israel Ukraine even Taiwan and the
southern border of the United States and
Mexico but it could be some time before
that money materializes as because the
House of Representatives is without a
speaker that means all legislation to
provide funding is frozen Kimberly hel
at Al jazer the White
House make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer